dynamic between the three of us was
exactly the same as it was 30 years ago
it's been nearly 30 years since we've
seen the Sanderson sisters because of
Bette Midler's yearly persistence the
cult popularity regardless of the
initial box office numbers and iconic
song and dance numbers we get a sequel
to This brilliant Halloween classic so
my experience was that it was a it was a
great success number one the best part
about being a witch find something
anything we must fly even in the
original movie The Flying aspect was the
actor's favorite part Kathy najimi said
in Hocus Pocus 2 that she had the most
fun flying on her cleaning supplies she
thinks they didn't do enough of it they
were the only roomies left Sarah Jessica
Parker loved being in the air so much
she'd actually stay up there between
takes maybe they'd go to lunch or you
know change the lens and I would just
stay up there she even had a way of
keeping herself busy I could fit an
entire New York Times up the back of the
corset she would just sit up there and
read the times as she waited for her
next take number two we're joined by
three new witches these women are so
talented Bette Midler describes the plot
beautifully pitting the young against
the veterans it's a conflict that
audiences like to see who's going to win
or is anybody going to win director Ann
Fletcher Builds on this contrast with
visuals throughout the movie we give
each girl not only the same color in the
vein of our witches Becca being Winnie
Izzy Being Mary and Cassie being Sarah
and their hairstyles in a way are
similar it's a modern day Twist on it
what other similarities did you notice
between the six of them number three we
have some special guests for the musical
numbers there were some stunning drag
versions of the witches that got to
perform on stage with them the drag race
Queens gingerman Kimura Hall and
Cornbread the snagite jumped at the
opportunity to impersonate the Sanderson
sisters apparently the Sanderson sisters
are popular characters every Halloween
in the drag community would not make
sense if there were not a troop of
Queens there representing the Sanderson
sisters the musical number was a great
time for both the performers and the 300
person live audience one of Kathy and
Jimmy's favorite parts of the sequence
was that Anne Fletcher let them improv
and let us come up with some of our own
stuff at one point I turn around and see
the drag queen playing me and I guess
the line written was about the queen not
looking great and me saying oh so I
turned around and said something like
Hello beautiful number four speaking of
the music another Stellar suggestion
from the three stars Bette Midler shares
that was our big contribution we said
they have to sing We Made suggestions as
far as songs were concerned and we went
to the barricades on that there are two
covers and two huge musical numbers
Sarah Jessica Parker said they would
have done three if the studio let them
the songs were specifically chosen so
they would appeal to a wide variety of
age groups number five another movie
that saw suffered major Cova delays you
have all these set pieces and all these
things you want to do and then next
thing you know your hair and makeup team
is completely as coveted circling back
to the music all of the rehearsals took
place during covet so Sarah Jessica
Parker wasn't even able to attend due to
her busy shooting schedule and all of
the covet scheduling delays she had to
learn the dance in a room by herself
from a video Bette Midler shares her
experience throughout the rehearsals we
worked hard on them we had rehearsals
during covid we went from Pillar To Post
dancing singing and carrying on in masks
number six a major distinction to her
iconic look one thing some fans might
notice is that her mouth is on the other
side of her face now the real reason
behind this was because it hurts Kathy
and Jimmy to do it on the original side
she did 30 years ago she actually came
up with a scene in Hocus Pocus 2 to
justify the change there's a scene at
the beginning where Winnie slaps me and
my mouth goes to the other side and then
she slaps me again and it goes to the
other side and sticks do you want to hit
me with that number seven the sweetest
zombie in all of zombie lore
stop I am a good zombie the original
actor Doug Jones comes back to play his
iconic role of Billy in the sequel aside
from the Sanderson sisters he's the only
other character to return not only that
but the Prosthetics are done by the same
makeup artist Tony Gardner Billy also
wears the exact same weight from 1993.
they had it on a dummy on display for 29
years they put it back on my head in the
same style it didn't even need a
touch-up the costumes were rebuilt to be
the same as the first ones so I look
exactly the same number eight where have
the Sanderson sisters been and how did
they become the way they are I really
wanted an actual backstory too the
Sanderson sisters this movie is going to
answer those questions Bette Midler
Sarah Jessica Parker and Kathy and Jimmy
also wanted that to be more present in
this film so much so that they pitched a
Purgatory scene idea they wanted the
audience to know where the sisters had
been but that idea ended up getting cut
down line what we do get though in the
opening scene is a look at the Sanderson
sisters living in the 1600s happy 16th
birthday tribe number nine you'd know
their voices anywhere
did you know that Sarah Jessica Parker
Bette Midler and Kathy najimi had a huge
amount of say in the way their
characters sounded in the sequel the
writers of the movie thought they were
the real creators of the Sanderson
sisters and their voices so they sent
them the scripts for notes they sent us
story ideas then Sarah bet and I would
have phone meetings with lots of snacks
and we'd talk over narratives and
character arcs number 10. we OBET a huge
thank you it all started when she needed
her Winifred costume for an event she
called the studio and asked if she could
borrow it but they weren't able to lend
it to her so she looked on eBay and saw
hundreds and hundreds of Hocus Pocus
costumes and memorabilia for sale when
she started realizing how popular the
film had become because it was
originally considered to be a flop after
it was released in 1993. she started
making some calls some legends never die
I love that she told Entertainment
Weekly as I watched it progress I'd call
the studio once a year to ask how about
it once the studio learned that they
could release it on a streaming platform
they were all in number 11. a one-time
only event to benefit the New York
restoration project which works to
restore Gardens and Parks throughout New
York's five boroughs the entire Hocus
Pocus cast got together for a special
reunion hosted by Elvira it was filmed
like a mock documentary about the
history of the Sanderson sisters oh
Master oh
you've grown so much
older not only did it feature the
original cast but they were joined by
stars like Meryl Streep Jamie Lee Curtis
and Adam Lambert The Reunion was also
available for fans to view if they
purchased a ticket did you happen to
catch it let us know in the comments
number 12. the creators didn't take the
reboot of this story lightly and the
number one reason to watch Hocus Pocus 2
because the Sanderson sisters will come
for you if you don't the film only took
three months to shoot starting in
October 2021 and running through January
2022 but they didn't actually get to
wrap there though originally shot in the
cities of Providence Lincoln and Newport
Rhode Island they ended up heading over
to Astoria Queens to reshoot the ending
two test screenings showed that the
audience found it to be pretty weak so
they rushed to reshoot it in June 2022
Hocus Pocus 2 brings us classic
Sanderson humor
1993 and fresh musical numbers what's
your favorite behind the scenes moment
[Music]